get out your school schedules 1 2 feet
and this is my best friend Katie we're
about to start high school oh my gosh
dozen three days oh my gosh that's in
three days it just might not be what we
expected why did he tell me when school
starts instead of seeing me everybody's
going to see cancer
hashtag here for you everybody's gonna
know me as the sick girl I'm so much
more than that what if you're not the
only one they're noticing okay Katie
you are the best friend that anyone
could all oh you just did I don't know
what part of school I'm the most excited
[Music]
we should probably go in Oh what if the
doctor doesn't clear me for school it's
gonna be okay oh I was talking to my
hair
[Applause]
[Music]
we are so amazing your attire is so
great mom you have a - cries a week
maximum don't go through in one day
what's so great let's do something our
moms will hate I was thinking more like
an ice cream cone there are certain
times in your life that you really need
a friend but sometimes you get something
even better you get a Katie now I'm
gonna see how it's going upstairs
[Music]
you